et gérard dans ce geste de christine
girard un mot s'impose enfin la
québécoise a d'abord reçu sa médaille de
bronze des jeux de 2008 puis sa médaille
d'or des jeux de 2012
christine girard savait depuis le 19
avril qu'elle deviendrait championne
olympique mais elle attendait sa
précieuse médaille des jeux de lons le
31 juillet 2012
elle avait terminé troisième de la
compétition dans sa catégorie des moins
de 63 kg c'est à la suite d
disqualification pour dopage des deux
athlètes qu'on voit sur le podium que
christine girard peut monter sur la plus
haute marche
six ans plus tard elle devient la
première médaillée d'or en haltérophilie
de l'histoire olympique canadienne et
elle l'a fait sans compromis on est faux
la preuve que non c'est avec un soupçon
d'amertume qu'elle a reçu sa médaille de
bronze 10 ans après des jeux de pékin en
se rappelant sa préparation pour londres
en 2012
ses soeurs que si j'avais eu ma médaille
en 2008
mes quatre années de 2008 à 2012 aurait
été complètement différente aujourd'hui
avec les deux médailles collé à elle et
ses trois enfants
christine girard rappeler que tous les
obstacles ne sont pas insurmontables
j'ai grandi en croyant que c'était
impossible pour monter au fil des années
une médaille olympique en venant au
canada
même quand j'étais à mes premiers en
effet que je croyais que ça impossible
qui maintenant j'en ai 2 sec tout ce que
j'ai à dire c'est croyez en vous faites
pas la même erreur que moi
les médaillés olympiques de christine
girard c'est aussi la victoire d'un
certain idéal pour radio canada montréal